as a Nobel laureate one gets asked many
questions some of them very peculiar
indeed but one frequently asked one
which is quite reasonable is what advice
would you give to a student hoping to
embark on a career in theoretical
physics now I should make it clear that
my only conceivable qualification as a
mere stripling for giving this speech on
behalf of my two very senior colloids as
well as myself is simply that I happen
to belong to that fortunate 10% of the
world's population which was born with
English as its mother tongue so I don't
know whether my fellow laureates would
agree with my answers but for what it's
worth here it is first if there is
something in the conventional wisdom
that you don't understand what are you
wait for as long as it takes and don't
be deterred by the assurances of your
colleagues that quote these questions
are well understood unquote secondly if
you find a problem interesting don't
worry too much about whether here just
been solved in the existing literature
you will have a lot more fun with it if
you don't know and you'll learn a lot
even if what you come up with turns out
not to be publishable thirdly remember
that no honestly conducted piece of
research is ever wasted even if it seems
so at the time put it away in a drawer
and ten twenty or thirty years down the
road it will come back and help you in
ways you never anticipated and finally
take your teaching every bit as
seriously as your research if not more
so